hello everyone and welcome to the final
game will be showing from the 2013
candidates tournament
it's the game you've all been waiting
for Vasiliy vancouver sees Radomir
Kramnik and as you've seen in my
previous video magnus carlsen lost his
last round game against Peter Svidler if
you haven't seen that video to check it
out it will be the first thing you will
see in the description below as you
definitely want to check out that video
before watching this one it will do
wonders for your vast knowledge now it's
not like Coulson lost his game and then
chromic knows that he can just draw this
game and become become the Challenger -
which won a tournament as both games
were played simultaneously which could
be one of the reasons why Magnus Carlsen
got in time trouble for the first time
in this tournament because you know he
made a move and he had you know walk a
little checkout kramnik positioning
Kramnik made a move also he was
constantly watching the Gosselin's
position so you know you don't want to
play like the best move and ended the
game quickly in a draw then Kramnik
would know okay I can simply draw my
game and you know I'm or I win the game
and then I'm the Challenger so we do
have some photos before we actually
check out the game here we have he went
to ready to make his first move then we
have another nice photo of you one troop
so I think making the third move in this
game and another nice photo from the
opening there's a lot more chronic and
eventually doing doing his one of his
things I will have some more photos but
those will come after this game so let's
see it we have d 4 d 6 e 4 and Knight to
f6 just a second
alright so the first defense and it's
very interesting white Kramnik chooses
this defense for the first time he he
says he wants to keep all of his options
open so you can't play something that
that was drawn like so many times during
this tournament or during some other
games he has to wait and see how
Carlson's game will go and then you know
try to create something
Knight to c3 g6 and Knight to f3 so
event who goes for the classical
variation not not the f3 Bishop III
Queen d2 so Knight to f3 Bishop to g7
Bishop to e2 so the so-called quiet
system we have castles castles a6 h3
Knight to c6 Bishop to g5 b5 now a3 h6
all three standard moves Bishop to e3
that h6 bone could become a target in
the future we have 'if I've D captures D
captures and here event to avoid the
trade of Queens and goes Queen to see
one and now the screen to see one it's
not a very active square for the Queen
but it does come with a tempo because
the h6 bone is now under attack so King
to h7 and Bishop to c5 activating this
Bishop very nicely and now the rook on
f8 is under attack rook to e8 and now
rook to d1 attacking the Queen the Queen
doesn't really have anywhere to go
because e 7 is covered by the bishop so
a lot of activity here for a von Schuch
Bishop to d7 blocking now comes b4
quinta c8 getting the Queen out of this
pin from the rook we have Queen to e3
and now Knight to d8 preparing ideas
like night to e6 in the future event she
goes a four we have B captures an A for
Knight captures on a four and now now
comes Knight to d6 attacking the Bishop
on c5 Bishop to c4 and now Knight to h5
grabbing the bishop does seem like you
know like a nice idea winning the bishop
pair eliminating a strong piece but
after Knight captures black doesn't
really have a lot of options here you
have to defend the f7 pawn after rookie
salmon but you can capture on a6 you
just want to pawn Queen moves now comes
rugby 1 and it will be too easy of a
position to play for white white white
is already up upon and with so much so
much activity could be could be that
it's even a winning position so after
Bishop to c4
we have knife to h5 preparing to bring
it the night over to f4 Knight to c3 and
now Knight H to f4
Knight to d5 now a nice central square
for the knight also challenging the
knight on f4 Bishop to b5 we have Bishop
to b3 and now Bishop back to c6 r up to
a 5
now with the idea that if Knight
captures on c5 rook captures or even
better Queen captures we have Bishop
captures Bishop captures and Knight
captures Queen captures and again it's a
it's a wonderful position for white to
play c4 is coming and the a and c7 bones
are very weak
so after this rook to a5 Queen to b7
we have g3 now kicking the night away
from f4 Knight captures on h3
upon sacrifice a very nice one by one
choke King to g2 knife to g5 and now
rook to h1 so eventual sacrifices upon
to start an attack against chronic skin
using the H file King to g8 they are
getting the King away from H file Knight
captures two Knight captures and now f3
and enforcing that efore pawn and now
comes Bishop captures Bishop captures
and c6 blocking that Bishop Bishop back
to c4 and now that you look at this
position a lot minute Romney is up upon
but eventually did start an attack he
has a very nice rook on the open H file
and he does have the bishop prepare
which fully compensate for the extra
pawn we have Queen to c8 and Queen to b3
now with a double attack on the f7 pawn
although the knight is defending it but
the knight on d5 will be challenged so
h5 Bishop to e3 now attacking the
defender of the f7 pawn and knight back
to e6 rook H the rook ha1 now that
Kramnik defender on the kingside event
will not transfer his attention back to
the Queen side and the week a sex pawn
we have h4 as a bunch of King is also a
bit loose there as he did move all of
the pawns
so Kramnik wants to break open we have G
captures on h4 now comes Queen to d8
attacking
the age for pawn and rook captures on a6
and here is a very interesting position
at the time this move was played and now
Kramnik has to make a choice the best
move here is actually rook captures on
a6 but if you do this if you play the
best move
then comes rook captures Queen captures
on h4 of course but then Bishop captures
on e6 rook captures rook e8 check came
to h7 and now rook to a-1 with rook to
h1 being a terrible threat both Queen
and King around the h-file and in this
position gromek would either have to
move the King back and I look back to a8
check or figure out something but
definitely out of this position kramnik
would not achieve more than a draw and
at the time this position was on the
board before
gromek had to make this decision if
Magnus Carlsen still had kind of a draw
position against against Peters wheeler
so he wasn't lost yet so Kramnik thought
if I play the best move I may you know
do do well in this game but I'm not
gonna become challenger to Vishwanathan
Anand so instead of Lud doesn't go for
rook captures on a6
instead he plays rook to see it which is
the engine's second favorite move and
okay
here what is the trade of pieces and the
game goes on you want to proceed rook to
h1 route to c7
now the night and e6 can move as the
rook is now defending the f7 pawn but
Bishop captures and now it doesn't
matter if F captures or the Elric rook
captures vanships next move will be the
same in the game rook captures a nice it
was played and now comes b5 Big B 5
because if pawn captures then rook
captures a nice is coming pawn captures
Queen captures and after King moves
Queen captures and g6 and this position
I will be too easy to play for white h5
h6 is coming Bishop can come to g5 it's
a very unpleasant position basically a
winning position for event choke so
after b5 rope to b7 now the B pawn is
pinned as the queen is on b3 we have b6
now so Kramnik this preventive and
restrict but now event has a beautiful
past beasts
v6 pawn c5 we have rook to be one now
improving on the B file Bishop to f8 now
defending the c5 pawn queen to d5
attacking the rook on b7 and Queen to b8
defending rugby to a-1 now with complete
control of the a file rook to e8 idea
will be will be a terrible threat rook
to d6 attacking the Queen
but Avant you don't care he proceeds
with his plan rook to e8 and this is due
to a tactic that a chronic might have
missed but it's hard to say because the
time control was already reached there
there simply wasn't a better move
so rook captures on d5 rook captures and
be a rook captures pawn captures and now
if I drew fees up upon and the real
problem is chronic cannot allow rook
capture some b6 it will capture some be
sexist played feel free to punish gromek
for this mistake you are lastly once you
feel free to pause the video and win
this game so I will give it a couple of
seconds as usual for those of you who
who were able to do this congratulations
you are an excellent supporter of
mistakes and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show of course the
move loses to rook to e8 and now there
are no defenses there are simply too
many threats Bishop captures on c5 and
Bishop to h6 so this will this this will
come as an attack on the pin piece the
rook is pinning the bishop and once you
prevent this with King the g7 okay now
you've stopped this but now comes Luke
captures on f8 and this is the move you
basically had to find the figure out
that rook to e8 was winning now after
King captures Bishop capture c5 this
comes with check and black is down a
piece and the white is completely
winning so after he captures on d5
kramnik saw that there is no way he can
capture this Bishop to d6 was played but
now rook to a6 pretty passive square for
the rook that is true but the rook is
nicely placed on a light square so the
bishop can never touch it and this pawn
is nicely protected a rope to be someone
was played and mouse
the king to f1 and it's very interesting
it was in this position Carson had
already lost his game against Peter
Svidler he was giving an interview
during the press conference and as
Carson was leaving the press conference
he asked the commentaries if he could
see add the position from the game
Avengers versus Kramnik and he saw this
position and Carlson said that Yvonne
truck was completely winning here and
that nothing could possibly go wrong
here and in fact nothing did go wrong
here as it was in this position right
after Carson said this that Vladimir
Kramnik resigned the game why did he
resign the game
well there is it's okay it's only a pawn
up but there is no counter play for
black here white white can simply March
his king of the board push the pawn and
win the game if black stops this with
his King
you know prevents the King from reaching
c6 the the white king can simply come to
c4 grab the c5 pawn then it's gonna be a
two points up pull the c4 pawn rook to
a7 is an idea there are so many ideas
here and all of them are winning so yeah
kramnik doesn't hope for a miracle as
this is one of the games in this
tournament
Chucky's is actually not in time trouble
so yeah basically if you look at it from
Magnus Carlsen did win the tournament
but it's a Chucky's last game that
actually won him first place so these
are the standings after after round 14
after the final round of the 2013
candidates tournament both Carson and
Kramnik eight and a half points the same
as after round 13 then almost they
costly almost caught and Peter Svidler
and Levin are in third and fourth place
with 8 points only half a point less
than chronic and Carlsen then Goethe
shook and Boris Gelfand with six and a
half Avenger with six and team or a job
of last place with four points so yeah
definitely a wild
tournament and not often will you see a
tournament end like this both players
you know had to really outperform their
themselves in the last round and the
both cost and and cronic lost their
games
bhadiya they both had 8 and 1/2 points
but Carson
more wins than kramnik so the idea
ditional criteria makes calls and the
winner of the 2013 candidates tournament
and he is the rightful Challenger for
the title - Ashwin at an island and
after we cover the Norway Chess
Championship then we will continue with
the series Carson vs. Anand their World
Chess Championship match so for the end
of this video I did prepare a couple of
more photos so let's let's see some of
them here we have a very nice photo
there's 11 Arjen smiling at something
and there is Boris Gelfand just look at
him sipping on that nice glass of wine
that that man really really knows how to
live then we have a nice photo of a
sleeve on Chuck he's not the one to
party you know the tournament did finish
but he is already reading a nice chess
magazine and he's preparing for his next
big tournament then another nice photo
magnus carlsen got his medal for winning
the winning the tournament and ice chest
themed the metal and for the end the
last photo will be seen from the 2013
candidates tournament a photo of all of
the participants taken after the
tournament so there we have it a job of
course and we shook our union and
there's a vastly one Chuck not really
interested in taking the photo Peter
Svidler lad amid chronic in the middle
and there is of course the man who takes
the best photos Boris Gelfand
and if you look at all of them they are
really all pale like ghosts except
together and he has a nice nice red
color to his face from sipping all of
that wine but as we've said that man
really knows how to live so yeah that's
the game that's the the entire coverage
of the 2013 candidates tournament I do
hope you enjoyed it and that you've at
least slightly increased you're already
vast knowledge of chess in general so I
would like to thank William Fusco
Carroll Kerensky and John star for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon probably continuing
the 2018 Norway championship and it's
very sad I will have to announce it that
ding leerin as there was a rest day
yesterday him and Vishwanathan Anand won
a cooking contest but the England fell
from his bicycle and rock broke his hip
so he had to go to do surgery and he
will be missing his fourth round game
against Fabiana Caruana today but I will
keep you informed as we'll cover at
least some of the games from round 4 and
we will discuss the situation some more
so yeah thank you all and I will see you
soon